[Music]
about to be the biggest
just
gonna watch this interview people are
gonna look back at this moment when i
answered this question like damn he
wasn't lying
my name is jack harlow i'm a recording
artist
i'm 23.
[Music]
my parents didn't let me and my brother
play on electronics when we were kids
so i say that to say i spent all of my
formative years reading
and in class i liked english writing
personal narratives all that but you i
became
10 11 12 and i started to hear the music
that everyone was listening to and
you know they're just not saying
hip-hop's the dominant genre but it's
honestly been that way a while for the
youth so
it's just something about the the
rhythmic side of it that was just so
attractive to me just
and i think that combined with
being a writer
storytelling
just class and i was like this is what i
want to do
i think probably the down moments
probably impacted me the most and when i
say down moments i mean
having to do shows with 12 people in the
room it's basically all the moments of
selling yourself begging people to
rock with you especially my genre is so
much about bravado and saying i'm the
man
and sometimes early on i was making that
music saying i'm a man and then i go to
the show and you find out you're not yet
and i think it really
improved my performance
my confidence
to struggle through
getting embarrassed basically
[Music]
if there was a new artist
you know i would just encourage them to
really try and tell the truth in their
music
it goes a long way to just be vulnerable
and speak from the heart i think that's
what keeps you here if you look at all
the artists that have been here for a
decade or longer
and
haven't just gone to the wayside
they're all truth tellers and they all
speak from here and it doesn't mean
don't make the party music got to make
some of that too
but at some point people have to sit
down and feel like i know who that is
[Music]